bonjour jean michel poivert et merci
d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
alors on l'a dit un plus de cinq ans
plus de cinq ans d'attentes avant
l'ouverture de ce procès notamment à
cause de la pandémie de coronavirus elle
comment expliquer un délai si l'on aux
proches des 17 victimes et aux français
en général c'est une
c'est une question fondamentale plus de
55 ans et demi d'attentes pour pour ce
procès qui ne qui ne prendre en compte
que des complices et un pas des palais
par les auteurs principaux puisque les
auteurs principaux de son pull up pour
s'expliquer alors si on fait un
comparatif par exemple avec des
attentats depuis deux cherchent en
nouvelle zélande qui ont eu lieu il ya
un an et demi le procès est terminé la
sanction définitive en nouvelle zélande
est tombé un an et demi de de délais
contre 5 ans et demi en france on a un
vrai problème on a effectivement vous
avez raison moi je n'explique pas ou
plutôt si je m'explique pour des raisons
mais c'est passé pas l'objet du débat en
un vrai problème de lenteur de la
justice et de réponse pénale
alors c'est un procès on l'a dit qui
sera filmé un titre historique sachant
que le précédent en france c'était le
procès du criminel nazi klaus barbie
c'était en 1987 à lyon
pourquoi ce choix de filmer ce procès
c'est un choix qui qui me semblent
rentrer dans une dans une démarche
plutôt historique et de garder des
archives de ce procès parce que c'est
les événements ont marqué toute la
france et les événements non seulement
cela mais surtout le cours de l'année
2015 et les événements de 2016 moi j'ai
vécu en direct à la tête dure et d'en
marquer en arc et la france il était
nécessaire d'en garder une trace une
trace historique une trace télévision
télévisuelle en espérant que ce procès
nous apporte quelques réponses
ce dont je suis assez sceptique quand
même vous le disiez instant vous étiez à
la tête du raid à l'époque quel souvenir
vous vous gardez de cet épisode sur les
épisodes qui vont être un vent être jugé
gt gt sur engagé sur sur tous les fronts
sur la recherche
on recherche des frères kwasi en secteur
police en secteur gendarmerie en
assistance de du gign et puis ensuite
sur mon secteur sur le secteur police
pendant la prise d'otage commandé à la
prise d'otage jeu à la prise d'otage de
l'hyper cacher à la porte de vincennes
je commandais à la fois le raid et la br
i on était dans une formation que l'on
appelle la formation fpn force
d'intervention de la police nationale et
le ministre de l'époque bernard
cazeneuve avait donné le commandement de
l'ensemble du dispositif le le lead et
le sentiment que j'en garde au plus
profond de moi c'est sur cette
affaire-là d'abord un énorme pour pour
le chef du dispositif que j'étais un
énorme problème une énorme équation à
plusieurs inconnues à résoudre pour
pouvoir à la fois libéré l'ensemble des
des otages qui a été pris à la porte de
vincennes il y en avait 26 et en même
temps en ayant le moins de dégâts
possibles parmi par lui mais trou parmi
les gens que je commandais donc c'est
une
c'est une équation psychologiquement
difficile techniquement pas facile non
plus et opérationnellement très
compliqué aussi
on a on peut dire que dans cette
opération là on a libéré tous les otages
et ça pour le coup pour tous les gens
qui étaient là pour tous les gens du ray
pour tous les gens de la berri mais tous
les policiers qui étaient là et les gens
du lait même les hommes politiques qui à
l'époque était au était aux affaires
c'est une énorme fierté que d'avoir tous
ensemble sauver ses 26 vie on vous sent
encore forcément un très touchée vouliez
vous avez vécu tout ça de très près à
l'époque qu'est ce que vous attendez de
ce procès historique
sur le plan sur le plan de la manière
dont les choses se sont passées pas
grand chose parce qu'on sait à peu près
tout maintenant les enquêteurs ont fait
du fait du travail important les choses
ont été ont été divulgués on sait
exactement comment les choses se sont
passées bon on a pas tout
enfin tout cas le la plupart des gens
n'ont pas tous les réseaux qui se sont
imbriqués de là dedans ça je pense que
on sera au fur et à mesure c'est ce que
l'histoire l'histoire va nous
l'apprendre ça c'est les choses se sont
écoulés de cette mallette de cette
manière ou de cette manière mais moi le
plus important j'en attends à peu près
ce qu'attendent les avocats de la
défense je suis en phase avec eux
j'attends à ce que on nous explique
enfin nous explique les gens qui sont
accusés aujourd'hui non pas les pouvoirs
publics on a trop l'habitude de les
accuser pouvoirs publics les gens qui
sont responsables de ça nous expliquent
pourquoi ils se sont ils sont partis
dans cette folie meurtrière et surtout
qu'on arrive dans ce pays aussi à mettre
en cause ceux qui sont derrière tout ça
ceux qui travaillent sur les cerveaux
ceux qui préparent tout ça les les
extrémistes de l'islam
les salafistes établir les frères
musulmans les toutes les wahhabistes
violent tous ces gens là il faut qu'on
en parle et il faut que l'on mette en
place et on a commencé à le faire il
faut qu'on continue à mettre en place
des 10 des parts fou des pare-feu voyez
j'ai employé le terme de pas refoulés
parfois violents dans notre société
c'est important de comprendre ce
phénomène d'extrait d'extrémisme
musulmans et de le combattre par tous
les moyens opérationnels éducatif tous
les moyens de la société merci beaucoup
jean-michel fauvergue d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
rappelle que vous êtes élue la
république en marche de seine-et-marne
et ancien chef du raid merci beaucoup